Hey this is Presh Talwalkar
A survey found that many adults could not answer math questions designed for 15 year old students.
In this video i'm going to present a couple of the questions.
Can you figure them out?
This question was missed by 25% of adults.
There were some people on a train.
19 people get off the train at the first stop.
17 people get on the train.
Now there are 63 people on the train.
How many people were on the train to begin with?
This question was missed by 46% of adults.
An ordinary, fair dice is rolled 420 times.
How many times is the number 3 expected?
Give these problems a try and when you're ready keep watching the video. I'm going to present the answers.
For the train question, we'll consider the number of people who get off the train versus the number of people who get on.
The 19 people who get off the train can be represented as -19 and the 17 people who get on can be represented as +17.
-19 + 17 is equal to -2
This is interpreted as a net of 2 people got off the train.
Originally the train had 2 more people than it ended with.
Therefore the train began with 2 more than 63 which is 65 people.
If a fair dice is rolled 420 times how many times is the number 3 expected?
In an ordinary fair dice, each of the 6 numbers is equally likely to occur so each number is expected to occur in one sixth of the total rolls.
The number 3 is therefore expected to occur in one sixth of the 420 rolls or in 70 of the rolls.
Did you figure these out?
Thanks for watching this video. Please subscribe to my channel. I make videos on math and game theory. You can catch me on my blog
Mind Your Decisions
which you can follow on Facebook, Google Plus, and Patreon
You can catch me on social media
@preshtalwalkar
And if you like this video please check out my books
There are links in the video description